I'll go sign up for this race and the
first 70 miles I hadn't sat down I was
drinking mileplex and Rich crackers so
Elite nutrition Elite high quality
nutrition so what happens when you're
that ignorant and you go out to do this
race and you sit down in the chair your
body's done when you sit down for the
first time in over 12 hours your body's
now going through some metamorphosis but
I'm sitting there and I have this urge
to go to the bathroom and there's a
porta potty for me that wall but I can't
get up because my blood pressure's all
messed up from my great nutrition that
was on and so I can't stand up I look at
my ex-wife I literally say I want to sit
on myself right now so I sit there and I
pick up my back and I'm peeing blood
down my leg and I have 30 miles to go I
end up finding a way to get through that
30 miles when I got done with that race
it's the worst pain I can't even
describe the pain in that last 30 miles
to anybody whole body whole body all I
could think about was I can't believe
what I just done